[Music]
look dollar Johnny
Jimmy la la la she died updating mama
died one punch man's been one of the
most entertaining and popular anime of
recent times that being said I settled
on a video highlighting the top moments
in one punch man that's right I wanted
to make a compilation that's all about
our beloved al beer a tad bit lazy hero
who sacrificed his hair for power I know
totally an original list video but hey
I'm a sucker for epic battles so put up
your dukes and get ready for this list
sorry Joe
we start off the list highlighting the
battle from the very first episode that
Saitama versus the giant man a regular
dude called marui gory became the
towering mutant menace giant man
after taking the ultimate steroid drug
biceps brachii king that his scientist
older brother created these two though
mainly it was giant man's doing while
his brother egged him on caused a lot of
damage to various cities finally Saitama
steps in and lives up to his name as he
literally knocks giant man out
I think you're not just got up in a la
Zumba
guna
[Music]
not straying too far from episode one at
number 9 we have saitama's next
opponents the subterranean people
keeping in the introduction arc this
next battle was a bit unusual first a
mysterious assailant attacked Saitama
while he was relaxing in his apartment
and when he tried to fend them off his
usual one-hit ko didn't work secondly
the assailant belongs to a large group
of creatures called the Subterraneans
their home within the Earth's crust is
overpopulated and have come to seize the
surface world for new real estate and as
if the regular subterranean people
weren't bad enough the subterranean King
is a total unit but it turns out the
Saitama was just dreaming up the entire
epic encounter the fight was wonderfully
animated it has some really great
hand-to-hand action
yeah
next on our list is the Shaw battle
between one punch man and the king of
beasts now this was a battle that surely
made our friends over at PETA happy I
mean they already accused Pokemon of
endorsing animal abuse
so I'm actually surprised they didn't
jump on this anyway for this battle
Saitama went toe-to-toe with beast king
an artificial mutant sent by dr. Janus
to capture one punch man so that he
could use him as a human research
subject however this capture dingo near
as well as these poor unsuspecting moves
thought it would as usual a single hit
from Saitama results in this kitty being
put down from a distant bowling punch
tens
you know punch
moving on to number seven Saitama saves
Geno's in the superhero series it's
expected for the titular hero to save
the damsel in distress
even though Geno's isn't a damsel per se
he was definitely in distressed and by
whom you ask
well as it happens he's in distress
because of a damsel that's if you
consider someone like mosquito girl who
absorbs the blood her swarms of blood
sucking insect servants harvest from
bodies until they're dead husks to even
qualify as a damsel especially
considering the fact that she was
completely merciless with the cyborg in
their fight literally cutting him down
to size by taking a limb and slicing him
open but just because she laid down the
coup de Gras Saitama went from one punch
man to one slap man as he pimp smack
mosquito girl into a truly bloody mess
across three buildings
cut the zip
moving on to number six its Saitama
versus carnage Kabuto for this entry on
the list we finally come face to face
with dr. Jenny's the insidious scientist
has only one more trump card left to
play and the name of that trump card is
carnage Kabuto dr. Genesis ultimate
mutation Saitama steps in and the pair
square off within the special chamber of
dr. Genesis secret base and it's in this
same episode that we learned the secret
of how one punch man came to be so
strong which as it turns out was just
basic training exercises taken to a
maximum level this leads carnage Kabuto
to take on his ultimate form carnage
mode and attack Saitama with full force
but then our titular character remember
something he's late for a special sale
at the supermarket this leads him to
punch carnage Kabuto into oblivion and
then whale in his lament just goes to
show you don't get between a person and
a store sale
or neighbors
five we have Saitama versus Geno's
though this was a practice bout genis
didn't hold back in any way we see fluid
motion focused animations throughout
this seed this type of animation style
is hardly easy to do so kudos to the
artists and respects to their surely
dead wrists for pulling off this
frame-by-frame feet anyway the main
point of this practice was for generals
to experience Saitama strength firsthand
after they both passed the national
superhero registry exam however he
wanted the bold hero to take you
seriously at first he didn't which is
something we've all come to expect of
Saitama at this point
so when Janus reiterates that he wants
his master to be serious in this
practice bout he gets exactly what he
wants
[Music]
kepta merci de Mishi we don't clean it
all day
or then all nights here
aw it stands out
yeah
at number 4 we have Saitama destroying
the meteor prior to Saitama coming in to
stop the meteor several s-rank heroes
made their own attempts to destroy or
even steer the meteor away but they all
failed
genna's made an attempt and seemed like
he could pull it off but he exhausted
too much of his body's energy and
blaster power that he went into an
automatic shutdown enter Saitama every
bit the badass he is as he goes up up
and away to blast through the ball of
rock on fire the animation for this best
moment is more focused on objects and
backgrounds which shows how much
attention the artist gave to this scene
again let's pray for the dead risks of
these hard-working creative people
he conducted a meeting
[Music]
at number three it's the battle against
the deep-sea King we've talked about
saitama's battles and best moments for
the most of this list so at number four
we're gonna shift gears and focus on
Genesis and Moomin Rider this time they
face the deep-sea king a tyrannical
ruler of the sea folk and just an
all-round prick who loves to hurt people
to things that make this fight worthy of
a spot on this list r1 Janos holding his
own even when the tides no pun intended
their shift out of his favour even
risking his life to save a little girl
from getting struck by the
self-proclaimed king's acid spit and to
the surprise appearance of c-class Hero
Moomin Ryder who fought with deep-sea
King even though he was severely
outclassed and kept getting back up even
when he was put down it just goes to
show you though it really isn't the size
of the dog in the fight but the size of
the fight in the dog
also don't worry one punch man arrives
soon enough I'm a deep sea king of fish
filet combo
in the second-last
top moment we're focusing on the s-rank
heroes in their battle with an absurdly
powerful enemy known as Melser god again
we're changing focus from our titular
character to others in this case the
s-rank heroes silver Fang atomic samurai
metal bat Bowie Bowie prisoner and their
enemy the monstrous alien Melser guard a
member of the dark matter thieves and
one of the main antagonists of the alien
conquerors arc it's only when metal bat
makes a surprising discovery of a marble
in one of the separated parts of Melser
guard that the heroes figure out how to
defeat this monstrous alien one by one
each of the s-rank heroes makes an
awe-inspiring display of their
respective skills as they crush each
marble this battle was hardly easy for
the s-rank heroes but nonetheless they
come out victorious and eventually
managed to defeat him
[Music]
tokoha
renewed - good
and finally ladies and gentlemen we've
come to the moment we've all been
waiting for the most epic moment within
the one punch man series of all time or
at least so far until season 2 this
moment about saitama's battle with Lord
Boris the Cyclops like leader of the
dark matter thieves much like Saitama
the intergalactic villain deals with an
existential crisis in which he lost all
three in life after becoming so powerful
how does Lord Boris remedy this by
launching an invasion on earth to find a
worthy opponent as suggested by a
prophecy of course and eventually his
search led him to me one punch man I
could go on about what makes this battle
number one on the list but I'll just
list the two main points the first is
that Lord Boris actually survives
saitama's fabled one-hit chaos and that
second is that this battles the longest
that Saitama has ever had with any of
his past enemies both combatants
exchanged blows and don't hold back
whatsoever just when it seems like Lord
Boris will win as he uses his ultimate
move collapsing star warring cannon are
balled hero in Alicia's his own final
attack the serious punch truly Saitama
is the strongest hero he's such a
Majesty's
marjina v
[Music]
so those are my favorite moments from
the one punch man series or at least
they are the best ones until season two
comes along and if you like my channel
then do subscribe click the notification
bill check out my Twitter and maybe even
consider supporting the channel by
donating to my patreon until next time
my totaku's in prop replica arms see ya
[Music]
[Applause]